años atrás enseñaba física en california
un día llegué a dar clase diciendo hey
quieren escuchar un chiste de física sí
claro venga la luz tiene masa no lo sé
tiene no ni masa para pastel de
chocolate ni dulces y gente del medio
vivo la clase seguirá la playa que
engaño pero espera no debería la luz
tener masa si tiene momento no debería
tener masa si tiene momento debería
tener masa y no todo el mundo cálmense
ya lo malo fue que mi broma no solo me
explotó en la cara confundió a todos mis
alumnos habían leído que la luz tiene el
momento y tienen razón la luz tiene
momento pero luego llegó yo a clase y
les digo ay la luz no tienen masa y
ahora mis alumnos están pensando pero
usted es igual a mb en otras palabras si
el momento es
la masa por velocidad como puede ser que
la luz que no tiene masa pueda tener
momento bueno tuve que confesarles a mis
alumnos que te iguala mb no es
precisamente correcto para las cosas que
viajan a la velocidad de la luz para
cosas que viajan tan rápido tienes que
usar la relatividad especial
no quiero tardar mucho hablando de la
relatividad especial en este vídeo
así es que vas a tener que creerme que
las reglas de la relatividad especial
tienen una laguna y esta laguna permite
que objetos sin masa puedan tener
momento ahora la mala noticia es que no
podemos usar p igual a mb para encontrar
el momento de un fotón la buena noticia
es que la fórmula para el momento de un
fotón es sencilla
el momento de un fotón es igual a h
sobre el ámbar h es la constante de
planck 6.62 por 10 a la menos 34 jules
segundos lambda es la longitud de onda
de la luz en metros ten cuidado no uses
nanómetros convierte los a metros el
momento de un solo fotón es
excesivamente pequeño por eso nos
sentimos que nos empuja cuando la luz
brilla sobre nosotros pero teóricamente
si tuvieras una vela solar
suficientemente grande la luz rebotando
en tu vela solar la impulsaría hacia
adelante gracias al impulso impartido
por el momento de la luz en fin un corto
resumen de esta larga historia nunca
jamás jamás debes usar te iguala en bv
para encontrar el momento de un fotón
siempre debes usar momento igual a h
sobre el ámbar